here again the latest phone calls
between vibrant Putin and President
Trump hello hey Blair did you see it's
Saudi Arabia I touched the glowy orb
thing yes it was a globe like the earth
I touched the orb come to Russia I have
[Applause]
led by administration isn't chaos
they're appointing a special prosecutor
you got to do something I mean I can't
interfere in the process of the American
metal in the affairs of your government
get ahold of yourself lad he just called
me later mr. giggle fit Vlad get you
visited the Welling world Israel yielded
bingo I even wrote a message and put it
into the wall but don't ask me what I
wrote because it's a secret okay
it's between me and God so don't ask me
I won't
fine I asked for the power of
invisibility so I could touch the ladies
but don't ask me who I was fine Heidi
Klum and early Jessica Simpson
remember how you and I were coming up
with business ideas yes I got one for
you the latter beer what your own beer
Vladimir preparation with good idea you
mean that no I've got to go okay bye
Vlad by Nixon
you
[Applause]
you